okay everybody it looks like it's a it's
a boy psychobabble again um let me see
if I can move this a little bit okay I
guess it's fine okay that's following
man that's interesting
okay anyway a lot of people thought I
was dead
we saw a lot of fake articles like
psycho babbles dad I'm not that I'm here
I've just been busy
I'm just practicing gaming now okay this
game is called the con fraternity of
toasts and I just it's a good game it's
a good game I hear hear okay let's do
this person II to enter oh my god is
actually pretty scary
blasphemous supermarket discount toast
we don't have any one price toast the
[ __ ] was that what the [ __ ] okay
okay let's see what all that hullabaloo
at picnic area thank you I hear
something
oh you better cut that out oh [ __ ]
help me oh my god this is pretty sad
get the hell out of here can't go
anymore did I mess up things blow right
there okay let's see here a move this
actually a little closer my face Jesus
okay that were you I'm trying to help ya
but I can't make it go can I crash know
what that huh oh is that an opening how
the heck did I miss that Cemetery it's
scary
what's going on over here toast toast
toast toast what is this
someone's in the middle becoming toast
you what oh my god
oh la cannoli I don't like that I don't
like suggested threats what is that sir
sir
what is that
can does not want me to go in there yeah
well I guess we're going in what is this
that's can't it's closed hey man it's
closed there a back door or something
I say I'm freaking light over there I
know you're not closed and they down
there now Confraternity of tells it says
is this way okay hey baby oh my god
who's leaving all this toast hair what
the heck okay whoa
toast praise the Confraternity and I
praise it
hello sir it's Jennifer that's a
Victoria okay what the hell is going on
in this game
there's the bus that crashed
Jim only a jump
kill all humans it's time to take
revenge what what is this I love
programming okay
okay the treasure it doesn't exist it's
in her hand a knife or as a hawk okay I
guess I got to go back up there there is
a door up there i seent it up shut aqui
eat this [ __ ] though thinking into me
thinking anything go anything okay come
on go I've gone whoa
didn't really expect this I am poor $1
please
don't I have a dollar sorry Jake we qrz
an okay you know I'll play along
you know I'll buy it you know yes no sir
pray and boss do you want to join their
Confraternity in front of me
that's your simple question no way that
these guys are freaking lame so I'm not
joining a fraternity
the [ __ ] is that holy [ __ ] I'm funny
little joke lol what I live I guess then
hope you understand the ports of never
contradicting your superior we will be a
big happy family join the converter ok
alright I guess I'll join this thing
whoa okay right point what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] is going on here uh hello tell
us when I took Laura turn you have to go
to the Saiga temple you would see war
does they remember have a strong respect
for the authorities don't don't bring
anything you go in here
toasts lace tests lace and I can't okay
and I know what a nice about me
is this what is this this is really
scary it's very just uneasy hello young
toast to join you at the pass to retest
the first time over difficult may 2nd
test will be parkour last says you'll
have to what and gay their maze
okay
I'm getting there I'm getting there okay
I can get it does it get dizzy okay okay
holy cannoli is hard
mm-hmm okay I really don't know where
the hell I am then okay I don't think I
better just gonna be magic door so mine
was like all right I'm gonna get my
thinking it was like all right I'm gonna
go as far as I can um you know what holy
crap this is actually pretty tough I had
a friggin die in here in this toast
world
oh great
is that like a clue
great I lost some toast world maybe it's
like in the middle
and I think it's a true maze it as I can
random open oh great well I didn't go
this way yet okay yeah I came looking
I'm looking
whoa okay this place is huge
I don't know how ever gonna get through
this
and the music is driving me insane Wow
okay I'm going in circles literally
you might have to come back from where
it came from like I don't you bet the
start I just had to go around okay
really don't know where the [ __ ] I am
that [ __ ] is the Confraternity again he
was way over here it's a dead end I
think yeah okay
oh my god you gotta be kidding me okay
okay
holy crap back here I went there I went
there I went there so let me just go
backwards now
yeah I'm going in a loop you can watch
the wreck I always go left
is this look really like insanely hard
frickin toast challenges so hard
what the heck I'm gonna die in here Oh
what no exit
okay let's haven't been here before
okay well they really got me I it's like
this okay the thing is like whoever made
this was like maybe this is their first
game was upping it silly Jesus don't to
go too far from this because it the
farthest I've gone okay don't make it
right there go there I can't go there
okay
mmm-hmm I go on the same loop I'm going
insane
okay whatever I do the classic like put
your left hand on the wall then I think
it works oh my god you have got to be
kidding me
you have got to be kidding me
and get the [ __ ] out of here I've been
losing my damn mind in here the music is
so bad
okay I can't go and got going going I'm
sticking left wall always
Tanner's already here
I'm gettin out getting there mm-hmm
yeah well this way Jesus Christ I don't
think I've gone this way in Jesus Christ
what the hell what the hell this is
actually maddening you may have to go to
that spiral thing it's just this the sky
maybe it's like a hint oh my god oh my
god okay
okay nope nope I have like no patience
with the game
nope holy Toledo
all they tell you no I'll let it totally
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
not playing this game
no this game thumb this games done this
games done
nice camps done no no no no